comme nous l'avions annoncé on va
mobiliser 600 gendarmes pendant la durée
du carnaval et l'idée s'il vient de
prévenir que la fête soit réussie grâce
à la sécurité donc on fait des contrôles
avant la fête ce soir il y à une soirée
très importante à bellefontaine
donc on contrôle avant contre
l'alcoolémie on contrôle la prise de
stupéfiants
éventuellement les armes c'est pour ça
qu'on est sur réquisition du procureur
de la république
et puis on contrôlera la sortie mais
l'idée c'est que les gens soient avertis
que d'eux mêmes ils sachent qu'il ne
faut pas prendre le volant en ayant bu
par exemple d'accord ça veut dire que ça
plus on avance et qu'on ira dans le père
laval plus des contrôles vont
s'intensifier
absolument on commence dès ce soir ça
c'est un message envoyé à toute la
population pour qu'elle sache qu'elle
doit être en sécurité
et ça c'est notre mission et ça va durer
durant tout carnaval donc je rappelle
les chiffres qui sont très importants
600 gendarmes
cinq cent soixante policiers cent
soixante quatorze sapeurs-pompiers cus
des marins à la fois de la direction de
la mer et puis de la douane encore une
fois l'idée c'est que la sécurité
permettent à la fête des tribus